for me the big one is courage it's it's
very hard to be a leader it's hard to
speak truth to power very often you
might be the one that gets in trouble or
lose your job anything worth doing comes
on the other side of fear it takes
courage to make money not money
that's why immigrants come to America
and make money they came with nothing
except what courage rise and shine it's
an espresso time what's that belief
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
make a difference using it so let's
start your day off right grab your cup
of coffee and sip on today's message be
courageous
over to you Simon signing what a good
leaders have in common they have the
courage to do the right thing they're
people of high character and high
integrity but for me the big one is
courage it's it's very hard to be a
leader it's hard to speak truth to power
very often you might be the one that
gets in trouble or lose your job it's
hard to do the right thing it's much
easier to do the expedient thing and and
it's also a huge undertaking to be a
leader every every moment of every day
it's kind of like being a parent so I
think courage is ultimately the thing
that separates the people who win from
those who don't having the idea is not
enough having Michael Jordan level
talent at something is not enough you
have to act you have to do and a lot of
times that comes from having the courage
to do something because anything worth
doing comes on the other side of fear
anything worth doing in your life is
gonna come with a healthy dose of fear
you're gonna be scared of doing that
thing if you weren't scared then it'd be
too easy then it's not being courageous
right you need to have the courage to go
off and do something big otherwise
you're playing life so small that you're
never taking any kind of risk and you
end up hating your life because you want
to go off and do something big I think
you already know what you want to do I
think you already know a lot of times
the big plan that you want to go off and
execute against you
don't have the courage to go off and do
it and so what I do when I'm facing that
situation when I know what I want to do
but I'm too afraid to do it I just make
the future fear of regret so big that I
have to do it
I equate this to pain so like if you
have a hangnail and it really hurts and
then you punch yourself in the arm or
somebody punches you in the arm you
don't feel the hangnail anymore because
this pain hurts so much that's what I
try to do I try to make the pain that is
in front of me this fear of failure or
whatever I need to summon the courage to
do I make that pain insignificant
compared to a bigger pain and I'll make
it psychological pain maybe I'm just a
masochist I like causing myself pain but
what I'll do is if there's something
that I want to go off and do but I'm
afraid to do it I'll just imagine the
future being so painful I'll imagine 50
years of not doing that thing of looking
back on this moment and saying I should
have done that imagine what my life
could have been if I just took a chance
if I just believed in myself more if I
just had a little bit of courage and the
more that I compound that forward fifty
years of frustration and pain and anger
then it makes the current pain of doing
that thing not so scary and so I have to
go out and do it I met up with a friend
last night he's an entrepreneur where
I've known for maybe 12 13 years and he
said you know why in the first five
years of knowing you you didn't really
push me that hard and then the most
recent ones you've been giving me a lot
more of a boost you've been really
telling me the truth you've been helping
me grow a lot more than in the first few
years that I knew you he was saying
thank you he's just appreciating it the
funny thing was though in the first five
years I still knew all those things I
still had those opinions I still had
those thoughts I still could have helped
him wasn't I learned so much afterwards
that now I could push him I already was
thinking those things I was just too
afraid to do it I didn't want to ruffle
any feathers I didn't want to make him
feel bad I didn't want to you know
impose my will what ended up happening
was I would see friends of mine make the
mistakes that I projected I'm thinking
in my head this person is gonna go down
this path they're gonna have a negative
consequence and then they actually go
out and do it and I try to tell them in
a really soft way they don't hear the
message and then they get go off and
make that mistake
and yes maybe they deserve to make that
mistake but I always take the
responsibility it's my fault if they go
off and do it and I didn't give my best
to help them overcome that situation or
avoid that negativity that is my fault
and so in more recent years I've been
turning up on my friends and maybe
turning up on you guys too because I
don't want you to make the same mistake
because I think if I can project and
predict where you're gonna be and then
you end up there and I didn't do my best
to help sway that decision to move you
to a better path and that's my fault
and so I have to have the courage to
come and get into awkward sometimes
tough conversations but the thing that
gets me through is thinking about the
future pain is thinking about you five
years going down the wrong path and so I
just find that as a really helpful
framework whether it's something for me
a decision that I'm afraid to do or
having a conversation that involves
somebody else you just make the pain in
the fear of what's happened in the
current moment small compared to decades
of future pain if you don't address the
situation right now you make that future
pain so big that you have to do
something in the moment now I've got a
really special bonus clip for you but
before that question of the day I want
to know what is the most courageous
thing that you have ever done I want you
to have a little bit of ego here I want
you to pat yourself on the back a little
bit on this one leave it down the
comments below let's celebrate together
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
espresso give me go
if I had this how many heard the same
before it takes money - that's not true
it takes courage to make money
it takes courage to make money not money
that's why immigrants come to America
and make money
they came with nothing except what
courage you lost your courage when you
got in the middle class you trade your
courage I'm doing good you think you're
doing good to the bridge Falls so I was
fully you know prepared to just play out
you know stand-up comedy and comedy
clubs yeah but there's something within
you that constantly push the edges of
the envelope wherever you were well or
at least took advantage of the
opportunities that came around and a lot
of it has to do with you know just the
courage to jump in I mean you know to do
films that are out of your so-called
power Ally as they call it is it takes
nerves you know so I have the nerve you
know and we'll see if I have the goods
but I have the nerve and yeah I I'm just
excited really about always changing
about crossing me back and forth across
the river and throwing the hounds off
the trail I love that just whatever you
think that just when we think we've got
you we know you you're off on another
route absolutely and if I feel like I've
been figured out boy look out I will
become something completely different
you know maybe I might might not want to
become something completely different
but Express something completely
different
I always felt like if the world is going
crazy I'll be calm and if and if they're
calm I'll be the one hanging off the
chandelier I want to challenge you with
one word the word that is most important
for any of us to have it starts with a
see I call it the C word is that big
word courage all of us need an extra
dose of courage I remember very clearly
and as I think I could still feel the
butterflies in my stomach of my stomach
turning I was 15 years old I was in
England and they said we are going to
show you how to up sail it looks so easy
from where I was spending I said I can
ace that until I got to that high point
on the mountain they put me there
harness me up and they said go all of a
sudden the butterflies show up I have
absolutely no courage every ounce of I
can do it was drained out of me when I
look down to the bottom and I was trying
to figure out I have never done this how
am I going to get from the top to the
bottom
it started with putting one foot in
front of the others was I shaking
absolutely
I even had a tear coming down my eye but
with some coaching and with a lot of
cheering I tell you I learned how to
abseil to me courage is not saying that
you don't have fear it's not saying that
you don't have anxiety I had to face my
fear I had to feel it and I had to do it
anyway and that's what courage is all
about you act yourself can I really do
this can i really go back to school can
I really heal after a broken marriage
can i really go on we all ask those
questions sometimes especially if we've
been through a storm a financial stolen
an emotional storm a relational storm or
even a health storm when those winds are
blowing it seems as if we're gonna
capsize in a sea of fear but hang on for
one minute life is made up of storms and
I've learned from sailing that it all
depends on how you are just your sails
to me riding through the storms getting
courage starts right here
[Music]
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon they
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details